Marvel Studios may have been giddy
beyond compare about re-releasing
Avengers endgame but some Marvel fans
feel differently the House of Heroes
launched a special version of Avengers
endgame in theaters on June 28 offering
viewers a chance to see this year's
biggest superhero movie with a few extra
features tacked on either end of its
three hour runtime not an extended or
alternate cut of the film the end game
re-release included an introduction from
co-director Anthony Russo a tribute to
the late Stan Lee an unfinished deleted
scene focused on Mark Ruffalo's
professor Hulk and footage from
spider-man far from home the final film
in Phase three of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe many marvel lights headed out
to theaters over the weekend to feast
their eyes on the Avengers end game
re-release and were solely disappointed
by what they saw from misunderstanding
what kind of footage the re-released
would feature to being underwhelmed by
the post-credits extras - even finding
the bonus content cheap-looking fans are
upset by the end game re-release and
they are tweeting that rage and see
Talia Romanov kicked things off saying
save your money for Black Widow 2020
instead of the end game re-release
because I've never been so disappointed
in my life
twitter user Natasha Rogers wrote I'm so
disappointed and strongly recommend you
not watching it is a waste of money
meanwhile biz gamer 9 said he liked it
fine but that's because he just wanted
to see the movie again if that hadn't
been the case I would be more
disappointed with what they added
seriously if you're going in wanting new
stuff then don't go at all and wait for
the blu-ray countless others were upset
with themselves we're not doing enough
fact-finding about the end game
re-released beforehand one fan said they
were quote literally a fool for thinking
that they would get to see the deleted
scene featuring Catherine Lankford as an
older Morgan Stark the daughter of
Robert Downey jr. Tony Stark the classic
blunders
Daniel 67 11 some things up writing the
deleted scenes they added at the end of
the movie were the most pointless scenes
it was a Hulk deleted scene and a far
from home sneak peek the only thing nice
about it was the Stan Lee tribute and
the pre poster many Marvel fans are
particularly angry about the poor
quality of the never-before-seen Hulk
scene film critic Kirk tweeted I am so
disappointed and furious with the
re-release of Avengers endgame the new
footage was terrible PS two-level cgi
with no impact on story and some fluff
content do not spend money on this added
users axia
to be honest the re-release bonus
content for avengers endgame was really
poor quality and almost looked fan may
seems like kind of a cash grab very
disappointed the idea that the
re-release was spurred by a desire to
make more money is of course obviously
true Marvel was specifically hoping that
revenue from the re-release would allow
the film to pass James Cameron's Avatar
as the highest-grossing film in box
office history as endgame entered the
weekend trailing by just 37 million
dollars it seems that some fans were
outraged by the lengths Marvel and
parent company Disney went to squeeze
more juice out of endgame with cheri
geese slamming the re-release as a
blatant cash grab by Disney because they
know they'll make millions off of people
who live and breathe for Marvel movies
to make matters worse Avengers endgame
didn't even end up beating avatar with
its re-release over the weekend taking
in just five point five million dollars
domestically it looks like it may never
surpass the Cameron directed fill with
The Hollywood Reporter writing that
media analysts believe that quote it
would be impossible for Avengers endgame
to top avatar
unless Marvel re-release the film again
at some point in the future everything
considered it seems like the bonus
content included in the Avengers end
game re-release wasn't worth the cost of
entry for many Marvel fans it's unlikely
that this backlash will tarnish the
studio's reputation given just how
beloved the MCU is but it will probably
make Marvel and Disney think twice about
how they approached rerelease in movies
down the line if they ever do check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite Marvel heroes are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]